some kids at the airport he goes about
to hop on my plane missing class to go
to vcon means I'm doing five hours of
homework on the plane see you soon I
quote retweet it homework life this
means he will do five more hours of
homework than I did in my entire High
School career combined I was laughed
that people like don't believe that you
never did homework forget about homework
never study for a test I never opened a
book that didn't give you anxiety for
what worrying about something that I
knew meant nothing so how did you
graduate I basically rolled the dice
listened in class for a couple grades
got these based on barely listening in
class listened because I loved history
so I got bees and then they just passed
me through because I basically like
halfway through freshman year high
school was like I'm gonna stay back and
then I kind of got like whiff of like
the school was going for like good
verification like Blue Ribbon or
something and I was like what does that
mean that means they want everybody to
pass and I'm like see ya